you
you
uh thank you members
council shrub
thank you
it is
uh good evening members uh can i welcome
you to this uh
planning committee meeting on the 20th
of july
on a very hot evening not as bad as it
was
earlier in the week i was advised
by officers that if any member here
wants to take their clothes off
um in any form
have i got that wrong um
they're welcome to but it's not quite as
bad and also as i say you are being live
streamed on television so it's up to you
whether you want to be seen or not so um
but please feel welcome and i'm wearing
a tie
if other members want to
feel more comfortable
please do and
uh sorry councillor bayford are you
removing something
no i'm
sitting up here and seeing no anyway
i better move on housekeeping as usual
if the fire alarm is activated
please vote the offices via the stairs
either through the security door which
is to my right or
the corridor and the stairs
but opposite the lifts please do not use
the lifts
assemble in holy square green and
officers will
come and collect you when it's deemed
safe to come back into the meeting
filming is anybody
in the public gallery or anyone forming
tonight
no thank you very much uh
restriction of mobile phones i would ask
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls in the
chamber while the meeting is in
progress
uh
members um are there any members
speaking who aren't on the committee on
under 20.1
i can't see anyone
nope thank you
public speaking the following
application has been reserved for public
speaking with members please make a note
item 5a which is a01
workshop 21 high
bernier street in ramsgate
make a note of that
thank you for that sir and moving again
agenda item one apologies for absence
i have apologies for counsellor paul
moore
and i understand uh
council david
your name's gone don't worry david
i should know she and i have done it
before it just
mr bollings
council bonus sorry about that
and also um
counselor
i thought so
i'm being hinted here i think it's the
heat getting to a counselor exactly
welcome i know you've been on planning i
also understand you've had the dreaded i
hope you hope you're feeling better
agenda item 2 declarations of interests
any members
there isn't thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning committee held on the 15th of
june 2022
do members agree that minutes of the
planning committee on that date be
approved as a correct record could i
have a proposal please
counselor heart
and second to please
cancer clinton here thank you all agree
thank you
item agenda 4
which is number 212 harold road in
margate this was in front of your
members you may surely recall
previously
at the may meeting of this year
i will now ask the planning officer
which is emma to outline
the report
thank you chairman
um so just to remind members then this
is the application site outlined in red
here we've got howard road on the left
hand side here um norfolk road um to the
east uh eastern esplanade above and the
site lies just outside the conservation
area it lies inside
the cliftonville west renewal area
the site is previously fed land
currently accommodating a garage
building and the site is allocated in
the state local plan for housing
so these are just visuals again of
of the site so again um just remind
members this is the existing site so
this is the existing garage building
um we've had road to the bottom of the
slide here in norfolk road um to the top
of the slide here and the application
site um includes this access point here
from norfolk road
um and then this area that extends round
here and also this parking area to the
left here
and then this is just another view that
was taken from howard road looking
towards the application site so again
it's this building here up to this point
here
and then again from the rear from
norfolk road looking towards the
application site
and then these are some photos
of the site again taken from howard road
so just remind members this is the
existing building on the site it's a
two-story and commercial building
and again this is the application site
here so it includes this area here with
the
parking and this large um building to
the rear of the site
this again the parking no to the left of
the application site
and then again here from howard road
looking towards the site
and then this is from
um further south in howard where looking
towards it so again you can start to see
um the buildings either side of the site
you can see the four-story flat
development on the corner and you can
see some of the um
more traditional buildings are in the
road that are generally three and a half
stories in height
again some properties to the right-hand
side so again the application site is in
this location here
and then again some other buildings
further down the road on the eastern
side of howard road
and then this looking back towards the
site on the right-hand side towards
eastern esplanade and again you can see
the
large flat development um frontier nest
grenade
and then this is on the western side of
howard road so opposite the site
and then again looking towards the
application site here
and on the left here
and again further from here so this is
again the block on the corner so this is
for forced in height and then this is
now from norfolk road looking towards
the access that leads into the site so
this is a existing buildings either side
of that access point
and then again you say so you can see
the application site is in the distance
here
and then this is the access road leading
towards the site so the application site
is this here and these are the existing
commercial buildings
so this is a block plan showing the
existing building on the site and this
is the proposed block plan so the
application is for 34 flats and three
houses so resulting in 37 units in total
and this is a flat block at the front
here and these are the houses in this
location here being accessed from
norfolk road
and then this is the proposed site plan
which shows 33 parking spaces to the
rear of the site and five to the front
and you can see the immunity space
serving the units so the um
the
report that went to members in may which
is provided within um annex one um gave
them the officer's views on the proposal
so in terms of the design um
it was stated within the port how um
officers had worked to reduce the size
of the scheme so originally it was for
39 units and we sought to reduce it down
to 37
and within the report it states how
officers are now of the view that the
size and scale of the development and
its location within the site um will not
have a detrimental impact on the couch
and appearance of the area
so just to show you the
elevations again so
these are the elevation plans this is
the front elevation front in howard road
so in terms of the materials it's a red
and yellow brick some metal cladding
you can see some
projections to the front of the building
so
imitating bay projections to the front
and there's a staggered frontage this
was the access point here which provided
the access to the parking spaces at the
rear
and then this is the rear elevation of
the block
and these are the side elevations so
just remind members that this elevation
on the left-hand side the north face and
elevation
had been amended as well during the
course of the application to introduce
um staggering and some openings in order
to improve the appearance of this
elevation when seen from the
conservation area
and then this plan shows the context of
the development in terms of the
surrounding buildings so again in terms
of
surrounding development um offices again
in the report had considered that given
the reduction in height because there
was a fifth story that was removed
and that the development would sit
comfortably within the street scene
and now these are some cgi's that have
been presented by the applicant just to
show members uh provide a visual of how
the development would look on the site
so you can see again the different um
brick and a
red brick on the right and some setback
yellow brick and you can see the
projections of these bays which are
metal clad you can see the metal clad in
a top floor level which
gives us sort of the perception of
almost like a man-side roof design at
this point and you can see it's
parapet roofs which is similar to some
other properties within the road so
again within the report um
within annex one officers felt that
given the range of different style
properties within howard road and the
the scout of properties within howard
road that this would sit comfortably
within the street scene
this report has been brought back on
given a members view at the previous may
meeting so
members
raised concerns in terms of the design
they raised concerns with the height
scale
and design of the building and felt
there was an intensification of the site
that would result in a significantly
large-scale building that detracted from
the character appearance of the area
and members felt that it didn't reflect
the predominantly traditional design
present within howard road
and that
it lacked any character and was quite a
large block that would not fit in within
the street scene and therefore members
consider that it would not make a
positive contribution to the street
scene or
the quality of the environment
as such a reason for refusal has been
set out within 2.7 of the report which
includes
the size scale height and design of the
development resulting in an obtrusive
and in congress former development that
fails to relate to the surrounding
development or make a positive
contribution to the street scene or the
quality of the environment so if members
consider this still to be
an unacceptable impact on the area due
to the design and scale of the building
then this is the reason for refusal that
is recommended
other issues that um were raised by
members at the previous meeting was
through the dorset play space so in this
plan here again you can see the communal
area
to the rear of the flats so we don't
have any set guidance on minimum space
standards for dorset play space we just
have a requirement that this should be
provided for any family unit of two
bedrooms or more which this development
does consist of all two or three bedroom
units
and the proposal includes a communal
space of 21 meters by 8 meters
approximately and it's considered by
officers that this space is adequate to
serve the number of units proposed and
therefore it suggested to members that
this is not um used as a reason for
refusal of the application
members raised concerns with the lack of
affordable housing that
um has been provided so a viability
assessment um was submitted with the
application as you can see within again
the officer report and from the the may
agenda
um
the viability report came in it has been
independently reviewed um we we've gone
back and forth negotiating with the
applicant to seek us as much as we can
on this site and the result is that
given the fact it is prevent land
containing um a garage it's it's only
viable to develop the site with a
contribution of of 125 000 which is what
the applicant has offered
um we have set out within the report how
we have intended to split this this
contribution so we propose that this
would actually be split between
um going towards the medical center for
um
as requested by the ccg and a
contribution towards special education
and towards waste
resulting in a contribution of 76
877 pounds towards affordable housing
if members felt that this was um
not
a good
um way of splitting this money we could
look at the full contribution of the 125
000 going towards the affordable housing
but any more than that and it has been
proven through the viability assessment
that um the site is not viable to come
forward for housing development which is
what we want on this site given the fact
it's allocated for housing so on the
basis that we have had that viability
assessment which has been independent
reviewed and it fully justifies the fact
that only this is is viable on the site
for the 125 000 contribution
it is considered that the scheme does
comply with policy sp 23 of the
authentic local plan and therefore again
it's recommended that members do not
refuse the application on on this reason
um further reasons for refusal have been
suggested which are just technical
reasons to refuse on the basis that we
don't actually commonly have a signed
legal agreement to secure the 125 000
the sba contribution
um and so those those are recommended as
well so the report sets out the options
within section three
um these include um
3.1 which um is that members could
refuse the application on the reasons of
the design reason which i mentioned
earlier and the technical reasons to do
the lack of legal agreement
or 3.2 where members refuse the
application for the reason set out
within 3.1 and any additional reasons
that members consider suitable
or 3.3 where members defer and dedicate
the application for approval and subject
to conditions and the legal agreement or
3.4 when members propose an alternative
motion thank you chairman
thank you very much
given the previous decision by members
to consider reasons for refusal
i move the motion at option 3.1 of the
report which would be to refuse the
application on the design and the lack
of the legal agreement securing the
required planning obligations only i
asked the vice chairman to please second
oh second nurture thank you councillor
coleman cook
members
council auburn
yes thank you chair i'm i wasn't here
for the
previous committee when this was looked
at by members
i have to say
i totally agree with the refusal
um i think the development is
architecturally
lacking in quality chair
um
i also think it looks like a school
development to be quite honest you're
telling a lot of college development
instead of housing
uh adjacent to the cons to the
conservation area
uh it's bulky uh it's not sensitive to
the street scene at all
and so therefore i've fully endorsed the
recommendation for refusal thank you
chair uh thank you councilwoman
councillor everett
yeah i'm happy to be um guided by the
officers on what the
appropriate reasons for refusal are in
this case but i just
like to express my frustration really at
the recommendation from the officers
that a shortfall of 15
on the contribution
is not significant enough to warrant it
being a ground for refusal and i accept
the accuracy of the advice
i just say it seems a bit ridiculous to
me if we say well this will be a
reasonable so the report says this will
be a reasonable sum 161 000 but they've
offered 138 000 and we can't push them
any further
and and i accept that may well be the
case but it does seem a bit ridiculous
to me
thank you councillor heart
thank you chair sorry for my uh later
ride we've got called in the traffic on
the sea front so i do apologize for that
um i remember this going forward to to
members actually and
no attempts to be made as i think i said
last time to even tie in the windows
with the other surrounding buildings the
one next to it so they're all off set
it's an enormous
building i think for the site i think
again this is another case of developers
trying to get as much out of the site as
physically possible and i just don't
think it's the right setting for the
area so i'm happy to to go with refusal
thank you
uh thank you councillor hart um do i see
councillor bayford
thank you chair just to say that i think
in this case as it's clear that the um
that members want to refuse the
application we should be
guided by the officers
to the grounds that we give because we
will have to be very careful that
we give ourselves a fair
fair chance in the uh event of a
an appeal thank you
thank you councillor keane
thank you i also need to apologize to
being late because of the traffic on the
seafront yeah i was here for the
previous discussion and i'm still of a
mind that this needs to be refused
on the grounds
written at 3.1
that seems to sum it up quite nicely i
just wanted to question
the
allocation of the contribution
because often in these
applications
we are giving money to the ccg often for
the lyme surgery and yet i don't see
anything happening there
can you clarify or can the officers
clarify for me what terms and conditions
are around this money given to the ccg
um
you know is there any timeline for what
it's spent on when it's spent so could i
just have some clarity on that because
my view would be that it should all go
to affordable housing
thank you
um so in terms of the request we do have
quite a lot of requests for
the same project obviously in terms of
you not having actually seen anything
happen it may well be we haven't
actually had the money come in so whilst
we may secure it on applications we have
to wait for development to commence
before we actually get any of the
contributions
when the money comes in they have 10
years in which to spend that money on a
project um as set up within the legal
agreement so
in this case we felt that in terms of
the split of the of the contributions
that because there were concerns raised
by residents in terms of additional
people and there'd been lack of
healthcare provision and lack of
education that we thought would be a
reasonable view to actually split the
contribution across a range of different
um
forms of infrastructure so in this case
we've got the
special education and the health and
then trying to get a little bit of
affordable housing as well but obviously
we don't have
anything that sets out our priorities
for contributions so that's just our
view on it based on the the request
we've received and comments from
residents
okay come back counselor
thank you for that clarification i'm
still of a mind that i mean the special
educational needs are slightly different
but that i would like to see the rest of
the money go to affordable housing
because the big problem with services
such as gps is not the building it is
the gps and that money wouldn't go
towards that thank you
uh thank you um
i don't see any other members wishing
to speak so members i'm going to put
this
to you you have the option in front of
you um
i put this motion for refusal as stated
in 3.1
to the vote those in favor of that
motion please show
sorry
hands down
as i'm asking that the money is split
differently does that need to be
incorporated in what we vote on
um
oh right right
okay yeah okay
okay
i know
you understand
yes okay thank you officers there
uh right once again i put this motion to
you 3.1 which is for
all those in favor of that option please
show the hand
that to me looks unanimous
thank you members there's no one
against and no extensions
right
that uh
motion has
he's in favor
please excuse me while i come back to
then just move on
it's done i thought it was
thank you for that members uh
agenda item
five this is a schedule of planning
applications for public speaking
and also note in your diaries um any
site visits will be on friday the 5th of
august
at 9 30 in normally
agenda item 5a which is the application
for approval
the workshop at 21 hibernia street in
ramsgate
speaking in favor of this application is
mr clay i think we have mr clay there
you have three minutes mr clay
thank you chair hi i'm mike one of the
owners of 21 hibernia street we're a
small local development company with
family and ramsgate and are committed to
delivering quality and design which
includes intelligent use of space
the aesthetic design of this development
proposal has been congratulated by
ramsgate town council and others during
a consultation
which is important consideration on a
site within a conservation area by
thoughtful design we've transformed two
flats in a disused commercial space into
eight livable units without needing to
significantly extend the building
an additional story has been achieved
with minimal visible height increase and
by adding dormant rear door windows
the additional space has meant that the
overall building footprint can decrease
allowing for new private gardens at
ground level and reducing the existing
overshadowing of neighbouring properties
there will be a net improvement to the
daylight experience by the adjacent
property a terrorist amenity space will
be moved further from neighbor's bedroom
windows and drainage to the site will be
improved
all units meet or exceed minimum floor
space and floor to ceiling
a mix of one bedroom two bedroom flats
and also a studio flat that gives
something more affordable and adheres
the new space standards that have only
applied to office to residential
conversions since 2020. as such the
studio unit will be larger with most of
the existing stock in the area the
layout also demonstrates a good use of
space with plenty of built-in storage
new doormas are 18 meters away from the
dormers opposite which is the standard
measures for acceptability of facing
windows and this matches the dormers at
neighboring albion court and the bedroom
windows on hibernia street
some concerns of over development
expressed during consultation appear to
be in relation to parking
we present the scheme as car free which
is now commonplace for town centre
developments across the county and is in
line with national policy to promote
walking cycling and public transport and
to reduce reliance on the private motor
car
we'd be happy to agree to a condition
requiring the flat to be marketed as car
free and to make it clear to future
residents that there is no on-street or
off-street parking provision in the area
in a no development scenario the two
existing flats have no parking provision
and the commercial space could either be
brought back into use or could be
converted to residential use under prior
approval without planning permission
which has the potential for more traffic
and greater parking stress however the
reality is that car ownership for new
residents is not practical and certainly
should not be encouraged the council's
highway department is in agreement with
this point and has raised no objection
to the proposal
a common issue for all development is
construction access but in this instance
is recognized as a planning
consideration due to the narrow streets
a construction management plan will be
put therefore in place to manage this
a large bin store has been included in
the scheme which has been sized in
accordance with planet's guidance and
for a property such as this the refuse
collectors will have a key to the bin
store to empty the bins and return them
to store without having them to be left
on the street
in summary the development proposal has
been extremely well considered and will
deliver a high quality development of a
character full building in need of care
and attention it will positively
contribute towards the conservation area
and will meet a demand in line with a
strategic housing market assessment on a
brownfield town center site where all
planning policy at national and local
level expects development to be
optimized
the proposal is fully policy compliant
and as such the office's recommendation
should be upheld thank you very much uh
thank you very much uh mr clay i hand
over to mr livingston to give uh the
report please
thank you chair
um the site is outlined in red on the
screen so as mentioned it's an existing
workshop on ground floor with two two
bed flats so the proposal is to extend
the building and convert it into six one
bed and two two bed flats so eight units
in total so as mentioned the site is in
the conservation area um
this is an aerial photograph uh just
showing
the the con the context of the site
and this is the building itself so
um
this is the elevation as you can see
from the sign that's on the building uh
the hibernia street elevation on the
left hand side of the image is the
cottage road elevation um so you can see
that there's in the existing building at
the moment there's a mix of of windows
you've got some new pvc on the left hand
side there
and some windows at ground floor which
are recessed with newer windows that
have been inserted at first floor level
um so you can also see in this image
that you've got some flint work that's
been painted over uh which comes up to
just below the
um
the top of the windows at ground floor
on the bernier street elevation then
you've got painted brickwork above but
you've you've got sort of painted render
almost on the um on the left hand side
on the frontage that fronts uh cottage
road
so this is just a view looking down uh
cottage road that runs down to the rear
access to the um albion place car park
that some members will be familiar with
and then
looking from
from hebernia street
this is the other elevation um just to
draw members to attention to the the
property on the right hand side you can
see that the existing building actually
protrudes out from that uh that
you know that sort of the face of that
building and that's just some context
that's useful to understand when looking
at the proposal
so this is a view looking back from
cottage road so you've got again those
upvc windows that are mentioned you have
an access to the workshop on ground
floor
you've got this side window that's quite
important when we look at the elevations
in a little bit
and you can see the tightness of the
streets here you can also see that the
site is surrounded by double yellow
lines
this is just a closer look in showing
that window and the existing
relationship with the development
adjacent
this is a view from google street view
so again cottage road so it's looking
back towards that corner this is just
important context to look at the
properties on the left hand side
which are the rear of the the list of
buildings
in in albion place and again it shows
the existing first floor windows and the
views that exist into the rear areas of
the properties on albion albion place
and then this is a view looking back
towards the site from cottage road so
we're directly next to the car park you
may be familiar with
looking back towards the property that's
then on the left in the center but again
you can see that you know the tightness
of that street and also you can see the
three-story building on the right-hand
side
so this is the existing floor plan of
the building so
you know currently laid out as a
workshop that isn't in use at the moment
and then upstairs you have those two two
bedroom units um you have a
uh sort of interesting arrangement
upstairs you've got a terrace almost an
internal terrace and then a conservatory
and the
and then you can see it a little bit
better here with the roof plan which is
showing where the terracing conservatory
is
uh just to give you the context uh the
applicant has provided um some 3d
visuals of the existing as well as the
posed
so this just shows how the property sits
within the existing development around
there so again
this is hibernia street on the the right
hand side of the image you can see that
the development adjacent next to where
that side window was runs the whole
length of this building and you can see
obviously where that conservatory is
there so there isn't really any
inter-visibility at the moment between
those two buildings and indeed there's
no windows that survey the property
effectively on those elevations
other than that side window that we
looked at on that photo
and this just confirms that so this is
showing the rear view so you can see the
conservatory you see the rear of the
properties on hibernia street which are
adjacent as well as the relationship
with the the deep building uh in the
middle of the image that you can see
that's that's adjacent on cottage road
so just to quickly run through the
existing elevations so this is the
elevation on cottage road
and this is the elevation as it is now
on bernie street
this is the uh existing sides this is
the sort of internal elevation when
you're looking almost from within the
building adjacent on hibernia street and
you can see the conservatory is in the
right hand side
and then this is the elevation of that
faces the the development next door so
you can see it's just it's just a blank
face at the moment because obviously
it's next to a existing blank face
so the proposal would increase the eaves
height of the existing building by 1.2
meters and then add a
a larger pitched roof onto the property
to provide some accommodation at the
existing roof level
um you've also
got a proposal to add some dorm windows
to the rear and this is just important
innovation to see the context of where
those dorm windows would look in terms
of their height so they would look over
the roof of the the development adjacent
um
you've also got a change in the windows
so this is a bit of matter that
we've received amendments on so
previously the elevational design had
these windows which are
a critical window so some metal windows
um it was that it was proposed to have
the
quick bit of maths the 16 but you know
the by four or 16 pane windows um
basically to match the two either side
throughout the whole building uh but
it's been broken up so that you've got
some variation in the windows um to be a
bit a little bit less homogeneous in the
proposal
then looking at the elevation fronting
hebernia street
what you've got here is again the
increase in eaves height
so it's come up by the 1.2 meters
you've then got v lux windows in the
pitched roof
we've got slate materials to match in
that
the proposal would
include the existing materials on each
face so what you'd do is you would
increase the amount of brickwork on the
hibernia street side and effectively
increase the amount of render on the
cottage roadside to try and match the
existing materials of the building
this is the internal
elevation i said sort of when you're if
you're in the building of um
adjacent on hibernia street um what's
being proposed is um a bit of demolition
of the existing building to create some
internal courtyards um and to alter the
building so i will show you with the the
3ds of the proposed what that
relationship is with the gaza neighbors
and then this is the new rear elevation
of the property again with the uh with
the demolition that occurs so previously
the elevation that you saw was just a
blank face with the window that's on the
right hand side but because of the
demolition of part of the building it's
allowed for the creation of windows in
that rear elevation but facing towards
the wall effectively of
the building to adjacent
so this is a 3d just to explain that
relationship so this is the the plan has
proposed
um so again you can see the the fact
that this building is set slightly in
front of the properties on bernier
street
as well as the obviously the change in
roof form you can see the relationship
between the dorm windows and the the
roof scape of the the neighboring
properties and so it isn't considered
that the development would result in any
impact on neighbours over and above the
existing because the dorm windows face
over the roof scape so there's no
overlooking no direct overlooking caused
by those dormers um the additional
window at second floor um at um fronting
cottage road um is is not significantly
greater than the fact that there are
first floor windows there at the moment
with living accommodation at first floor
at the moment
um design wise
this is approach that's been taken to
reuse the existing building but alter it
um has been endorsed by the conservation
officer in terms of trying to maximize
the building that's that's already there
that that has
an element of merit i think within the
conservation area um it's obviously um
it has got additions to it which are
non-traditional and therefore this will
give a more consistent pattern and
obviously removing upvc in a
conservation area is is a matter that is
supported
just to show you the rear elevation to
give you some of that again that context
of what's happening so that demolition
that's occurring to create a small
courtyard and to give an element of
outlook um has been provided which you
can see here
you can see that the building in terms
of the relationship with the neighboring
property on hibernia streets on the left
hand side
is no not significantly different from
when there was a conservatory there and
a brick face adjacent
and again clarification on where those
windows are that they would effectively
look onto
the over the roof scape or onto the
existing boundary wall
with the neighboring property
so in terms of the proposed layout
so all of the flats that are proposed
meet the space standards that are
required for the different types of
accommodation with the one bedroom units
as well as then the two bedroom units
the report outlines
one point with regards to flat 2 which
is the central unit in the image that
you can see
nearly all of the units are open plan in
terms of their layout
and in terms of when they are relying on
rear-facing windows that face towards
the wall
they also have usually a dual aspect
they've also got windows facing out on
cottage road or on hibernia street flat
2 is the exception to that in the sense
of that there is a
bedroom window that is on facing
hibernia street and then you have two
windows that are facing towards the wall
at the rear next in the kitchen and
living area
so that is something that's that's been
raised in in our view because of the the
size of that unit and the open plan
nature of that main area as well as the
fact that actually that's the unit that
has an external terrace which obviously
is being created for this unit it's not
considered that that unit by virtue of
that restricted outlook
is is insufficient in terms of quality
when assessed against um qdo3 in terms
of the living conditions for new
properties
it's worth noting on this plan as well
mentions been made of the bin storage so
in the top left of the image that you
can see there
you've got the bin store which is
effectively reusing that access to the
workshop
that that's been mentioned so that's a
you know direct access in terms of both
collection and storage point being the
same
you've also got a central excuse me a
a central communal access which includes
some bike stores as well
one point again that's raised in the
report when you look at the first floor
plan
um
is that um
i'm sorry actually it's the it's the
second floor plan i'll i'll come back
i'll come back to that point in one
second um these these units
are all one bedroom unit so they're not
required to have any external um space
but they all meet the required standards
and again you can see that point about
the main living areas all have aspect
that faces out over onto hebrew street
or cottage road
in terms of flat seven that's on the
left-hand side
this is a two-bedroom unit
and with regards to specific policies
about um requiring a private amenity
space this property wouldn't have
private immunity space
again this is considered in the report
um
you know and given
the fact that this is a almost a
landlocked site they are uh proposing to
demolish some areas to create some
external space um in terms of conversion
of the building given its location close
to our place gardens as well as
obviously um you know the town centre
location it's not considered the the
lack of a place base for this or sorry
private immunity space for this
particular unit on its own would warrant
refusal given the standard of
accommodation again the size of it
etc
um this is the
just a roof plan um again showing the
the flat roof at the top which is
reusing the existing building
the dorm windows and the the v-luxes
um so concern is raised and has been
raised in comments um about the fact
that the proposal doesn't include any um
parking uh provisions so no off-street
parking again it's a development that
it's a building that's already there it
doesn't have any parking serving the
existing uses as mentioned the ground
floor uses a you know could be reused as
a workshop as well as the fact that
you've got two two bed units at first
floor
so in terms of considerations for
highways um this plan identifies in the
blue shaded area where the town center
is in terms of the court commercial
center and the black dotted line is the
line that
delineates uh policy tp06
which is the area within the town center
where
no off-street parking is required to be
provided in development proposals so we
are outside the area if i hopefully you
can see my my mouse pointer basically
um you're just down the other end of
cottage road i think it's probably about
100 meters
from effectively where the boundary is
so the main two issues to consider when
there's a lack of parking is whether or
not there's an issue created in terms of
highway safety from the development or
whether or not there's an issue created
in terms of highway amenity for both
future occupiers but also existing
occupiers
so in terms of
in terms of the highway safety issue as
we've seen from the photos there are
existing on-street controls directly in
front of the property
on hibernia street and cottage road so
there are yellow lines
there is an added element obviously with
the previous use as a workshop and two
flats in terms of no off street parking
clearly the reuse of the existing
building would
create demand in the existing area and
the report outlines there is limited
on-street parking available in the
vicinity of the site
um
we don't consider the development would
result in safety issues because of the
fact that they're on street controls
if there was say no on-street controls
and you had the potential for people to
be parking on street on these streets
given the narrowness in terms of turning
around that would be a certainly a
highway safety concern but given the
on-street controls there we don't think
there is a highway safety issue that
certainly wouldn't be able to be
sustained
so therefore that leads to the
discussion about the immunity for the
existing and future residents now given
the previous use and the very close
proximity in terms of town center
location it's not been considered
sufficient by officers to refuse the
application on the additional demand for
spaces over and above
the fact that there is an existing
uh allowance from a workshop at ground
floor with however many employees could
go into that use and
and the two flats above
there is also any impact or concern
about impact has to be weighed against
the benefits of the fact that this is
developing a a you know a brownfield
site for residential units which meet
the sufficient standards in terms of
sizes as well as the improvements that
are made to the conservation area
in this instance a unilateral
undertaking has already been provided to
secure the contribution from these
additional units to the special
protection area and the sams project
and therefore the application is
recommended for approval with subject to
the safeguarding conditions as as
outlined thank you chair
uh thank you very much ian i moved the
office recommendation which as you
understand is for approval vice chair
please second
oh second nature thank you council
coleman cook members
council robin
yeah thank you chair um as a wall
councillor here
um
with my colleague councillor crittenden
i know that she has concerns about
parking and she will no doubt speak that
i'm preempting i'm sorry um it's been
told off um
the design i think absolutely fits in
there with the conservation area on
i think that
the design is good
there is
certainly a need for one bedroom flats
um
as i said it's a sensitive
design that fits in i believe
um
especially altering the buildings to
to fit in
the much needed accommodation
so
overall chairman
even though there might be parking
issues at some time in the future
i thoroughly support this this
application thank you chair
uh thank you very much councillor and
cancer clinton
thank you um well it was me that called
it in um
i will start by saying that i actually
think that uh changing the use from
factory to residential is appropriate
and i do very much like the
architectural design
but i am concerned along with the other
surrounding residents about the impact
on parking i appreciate what kcc's
advice is and i appreciate what the
developers said about advertising this
as a site with no parking available
but we do and councillor auburn will
know we do have considerable problems in
this area in the surrounding roads there
is no parking here um
our waste services also have
considerable problems with often missed
uh bing collections because people are
in the surrounding roads trying to
squeeze into every available space
the
park in
camden
camden square lobel alliance square
is increasingly being parked on because
there is nowhere else and around arklow
square which is also just off of here um
there are cars parking all four wheels
on the pavement
and i say that just to give an example
of just how severe it is in this area
it's a part it's one of the areas that
is was behind the motion i brought some
while ago with regard to having a
parking review
effectively across the whole of thanet
because this area is just outside of the
king street area
where we've had a number of new
developments all of those developments
are within
the restricted area for no requirement
for parking
um
but they have had quite a considerable
impact on the surrounding areas and my
concern with it just remains that we are
increasing it from two units to eight um
and that and whilst we can say
these are units with no parking we
actually have no control over the people
who who buy the property or move into it
at a later date and and parking really
is a very severe issue in this area and
that's the point that i wanted people to
members to consider
uh thank you for that count to brendan
councillor heart
thank you chair um the gentleman who put
forward the proposal very well spoken
got in time as well um said the rams
gate town council congratulates the
applicant on the appearance well i i
totally agree with round gate council it
looks lovely but he didn't carry on to
say that um they feel it's over
developed etcetera so are these he's
some missed a point there but i do feel
this is a good use of space however i do
agree with council criminal that is not
there's no parking you cannot guarantee
somebody who buys a house doesn't have a
car and if they say it's only going to
be people who have got a car they lie
and just say well i've got a car and
then put one into the car parking
yellow lines are wonderful um they're
the absolute superb thing to have around
the building as you can't park they're
only as good as enforcement officers who
walk the area so it doesn't really
matter what lines you put down if
they're not in fault it makes no
difference at all and i know the road's
tight
um
it's a difficult one this because i i
think you can't guarantee who's going to
buy a property at all and i think that
if you've got this many flats in them
some are going to going to want a car
and i think the issue we have is there's
zero parking and with regards to you
know you saying that this was a workshop
etc people who worked in the workshop
could quite probably just park their car
inside it it's big enough it's got
garage doors so um there might have been
spaces for people to actually park
inside um so i think um maybe they
should have got rid of a flatter and
just put parking underneath that's just
a comment i've got in a moment thank you
thank you council i'll bring back ian on
that uh your points so that in terms of
the potential for the existing building
to accommodate parking or the proposed
book both existing and proposed
um so from the information that that
we've had access to
um that those doors um effectively you
can't fit and get out a car
in that into inside the the ground floor
of the the building
i just want to draw members attention to
another point which is in the report
about the impact on the conservation
area if actually what you have to do is
you know get parking on site how it by
whatever means
actually how safe that would be one in
terms of if you're putting a vehicle say
for example if you're looking at the
image that is there and you look at that
area which is the flat roof area the
two-story bit if you were to demolish
that to say get a parking space a single
parking space into the development and
you reduce the number of units by by one
say to do that you wouldn't get any
sufficient visibility to be able to pull
out of that access because it's so tight
around there so providing actual parking
on site is it would actually increase a
problem with highway safety in our view
plus then there's the consideration of
what you do in terms of the conservation
area which the aim of a lot of policies
in the conservation area including tp06
is basically saying that parking off
street parking in a conservation area
doesn't actually reflect the historic
character so to create that you
potentially are even doing some
detriment to it i do accept the point
that what you're doing is increasing the
number of residential properties here
but we think that with offsetting the
fact that there is a workshop at ground
floor
there would potentially be a net
increase in demand for parking the area
that's not that's not disputed and
obviously we cannot as you say control
who has a current who doesn't even if
they're marketed in certain way does not
stop or prohibit someone from buying a
car
but given that number given the existing
use and given the fact that there are
the on-street controls in the area and
it's it's very centrally located
we certainly don't consider that any
refusal on grounds of lack of on-street
parking in this oh sorry lack of parking
could be sustained given the benefits of
the scheme in our view that is thank you
chad
uh thank you very much jane the council
of effort
thank you chair
yeah i
you know that
limited parking in town areas is a
national policy
we need they desperately need properties
of this kind
these are well designed they fit very
very nicely into the space um complement
the
conservation area
i think
that it would be unlikely that someone
who should ride a car would want to live
there be to be honest they know the
situation if they do then they will have
to manage that but
i think that it would it would not be a
good enough reason to refuse this
application i'm very happy to support it
thank you
thank you cancer over it
yeah i'd like to join the
congratulations to the developer
actually on the design because i think
it's a wholly appropriate design for the
location
i think it's a nice looking building and
an improvement obviously on the state of
what is there at the moment
um
i think we perhaps lose sight slightly
when we talk about the car issue of the
fact that i mean those those narrow
streets clearly are not of a modern
design and we wouldn't create them now
but the fact they're there is part of
ramsgate's charm and what's protected in
the in the conservation area um and
they're important to ramsgate so i think
it is inevitable that there will be
people who live in those flats who will
have cars
and that will add to the problem but as
has been said
um there is an existing potential to
generate traffic
existing use of the building um and i
just don't think there's any basis that
we can or even should consider refusing
it um on the grounds of parking so i'm
happy to support it
thank you very much uh council ghana
thank you yeah um
i just wanted to also comment on the car
situation i mean obviously
theoretically the less cars
there are the better and i'd love to see
uh
society where we didn't need as many
cars because it was easier to
cycle
and we had public transport
infrastructure
to cater for people they didn't need a
car
and i guess that requires a
sort of a strategy
for all of us councils district county
and our
public transport providers to
to get together and provide something
better for the residents of thana and
the rest of kent so i just hope that um
with the i know there are a number of
proposed bus cuts
coming up that stagecoach are proposing
i just hope this development isn't near
one of those bus services that actually
these future residents if it's approved
will not now be able to use thank you
thank you councillor wing
i was at that ramsgate town council
meeting and yes we we love the design
and it is great to see a brownfield site
coming forward instead of
grade one agricultural land which is
it's so depressing i i do i do think the
parking is an issue i live in central
harbour my ward is central harbour and
uh there is constant conflicts between
residents over over over
over uh
pressure on parking spots and we mustn't
forget that in the local plan it
actually states that for every 116
people that work 100 of them have to
leave thanit for employment so i sit
here as a green councillor desperately
wanting people not to use their cars i
have a car but the reality and the
context of people's situations is they
have to have a car because most people's
forms of employment are outside the area
and our public transport is is not great
we've also got cuts to buses but i'd
like to raise another concern
with the two-bedroomed flats that
likelihood is that is going to be a
family so there will be kids and i've
got quite a strong concerns over some of
the flats having no outdoor space not
even a small balcony to sit on not even
not even a
a small play area combined to it i know
you can walk down the road and you're on
the beach within within four or five
minutes but that does concern me that
that on some of the uh on some of the
flats on the on the i think it's the top
two there is the top one there is very
little outdoor space and if they're two
bedroom flats then then they're going to
have children there so i
i think it's over development we we
clearly said that at ramsgate town
council i'd like to see the reduction of
two flats which would obviously reduce
the pressure on parking and also maybe
create a situation where there could be
more outdoor space for people so i won't
be supporting it i'm afraid but i do
congratulate the the developer on the
use of brownfield site and the design i
think it's great
uh thank you swimming counselor pat
moore
thank you chairman uh
i don't know what the fuss is about the
cars because
how far is it to staffordshire street
car park i could do it in 10 minutes but
fit people can do it in five
so it's not
an issue as far as i can see and also
it's just come up about children playing
it's almost next door to albion gardens
nice place to play for children
i would agree to it
more i thought you could have walked
that distance in two minutes
uh
councillor zesky
thank you chair yeah i think the
development looks very good it fits the
site nicely
parking if you've got a car and you need
parking then you're not going to buy a
flat there
if you've got a family
and you need outdoor space you're not
going to buy a flat that hasn't got one
so i don't have an issue with that at
all like i can see a second bedroom
being used as for visitors etc but uh
just because you've got two bedrooms
doesn't mean you're going to have a
family sitting there um yeah i'm quite
happy to support this
uh thank you did you indicate don't want
to come back councillor heart yeah just
a quick question chet um ian did
indicate earlier on where all the bikes
were going to go um and he didn't
actually come back to that if he could
just tell us how many bikes are being
able to park thank you
yes um well i'd love to show you but i'm
having a bit of technical issues with
the um
the the chromecast at the moment but for
whilst it's on here
very quickly i'm going to show you that
it's the ground floor
um so you've got the the access the
communal access on
bernier street right in the center there
goes in and then
if you go past the staircase basically
you've got the bike store internally
from that communal space there so it's
got capacity for um it's one two three
four five i think it's certainly at
least a space per unit if not actually
it's probably about ten for the eight
basically
thank you thank you ian
okay members i think once again that's
been debated very well and i'll put this
to yourselves to vote
which is for approval so those in favor
could they show hands please
those against
any abstentions
that is carried thank you very much
members
thank you
right that concludes uh public speaking
for this meeting i'm going to ask
gabriella
clark she would read out
the the only item left um if there is
any member wishes to speak on that
please could they show the hand thank
you
yes
um
is that personal or um
call it out first of all and we'll agree
to it and then you can
say what you like within reason thank
you
5b d02 15 park lane birchington
thank you gabriella
you
sure right thank you very much um
okay i'm gonna pass that over to uh
yourself in thank you
uh
thank you chair um
as as i just mentioned if if the screen
goes off for whatever reason we might
have to just have a short adjournment to
just reset the system but hopefully it
will
persist and carry on um
okay
so the sighting question is outlined in
red on park lane in birchington so the
proposal is for
the erection of a
part two story part single story
building including six flats so five one
bed and one two bed
flat
excuse me following demolition of the
existing single story building
so this is an aerial image of the site
so
you'll see that the existing single
story building where the mouse pointer
is is set forward of the predominant
building line on park lane um to the
south
um
let's go down and just to show them the
context so there's number 15 set forward
so the red line that you can see there
denotes the conservation area so to the
north of that red line you're in the
conservation area birching to the south
of it you're outside so the site is
pretty much adjacent to conservation
there's a footpath the public footpath
that runs along the side of the site
but you're pretty much adjacent to the
conservation area
so this is the site
in question it's the main issues for
moments to consider on this application
the principle of development
the
impact on the character and appearance
of the area including the adjacent
conservation area impact on neighbouring
uh properties
and the impact on the highway network so
you can see at the moment that you've
got the existing building and then
you've got um open
space so it's private open space this
site
clicking through so this is a view
looking to the south down park lane so
you can see the front of the building so
it's it's single story but with a
relatively high pitched roof
then looking down so this is standing on
the public right of way so this runs
down to an alleyway that runs to
linnington road
so you can see the extent of the site
this is then further down into the site
looking back towards that single story
building so you can see the neighboring
property
on the the left hand side
which is number 23 park lane
and then this is standing in the site
looking towards that alleyway
so you can see that the brick wall
that's there is is basically the line of
conservation area so that is the the
conservation area the other side and
that's number 17 park lane you can see
there
so you've got a rather large tree as
well on the right hand side that is
right in the corner of the application
site
so this is just the other view looking
back from the rear of the site looking
back towards number 17 so
facing on to the site
and then this is standing in the alley
looking again towards that big tree and
the rear of the properties on linnington
road
this is just uh this is an isometric
view from from google so it's it's you
know it's been
projected out from satellite imagery but
hopefully this gives you an idea of the
form of development around there the
scale of the buildings that are there at
the moment as well as how this current
building sits within the context of the
area
so this is a view
actually from effectively linnington
road is behind the
the photo and we're looking towards the
site so you can see that that is the
tree that we saw in the back corner of
the site so this alley is um is is that
part of the public driveway which
accesses park lane from livingston road
and vice versa
so just a few
images showing you again a bit more
context of park lane so this is the
site's on the right hand side here we're
looking towards the route that runs down
to the square
with
the properties that are sort of directly
onto park lane
and then looking to the right hand side
of the existing single-story building
with the semi-detached properties
and then there's a view
of the other side looking towards the
site showing
uh the existing visibility of the single
story building
on site
so this is just an elevation uh just
showing you the existing so you can see
the existing on the bottom image there
um you can see the existing single story
building uh in its context with the the
properties around it
so the proposal is to
demolish the existing building and
create a building which
would contain the the six flats as
mentioned so the proposal would build in
place of the existing building
so where the number 15 is on the image
this shows a single story element that
we'll show you in the elevations
which is set forward of the existing
building line to
mimic the building that was there within
the bulk of the building set back in
line with number 23 adjacent
so just looking at that
ground floor plan and site plan
you've got on the left hand side of this
image is park lane so you've got the
grass verge that you saw in the photos
then you've got the single story element
here
and the reason why
i'm showing members this context is just
to show the different
articulation in the building itself so
you can so that when the the elevations
are shown there's the context of that
you can also see how at the rear of the
building um
the the elevation is set quite
significantly in from uh elevate the the
neighboring boundary with number 23 and
you can see the rear the cycle store the
bin store and the the tree to be
retained which is in the right hand
image so that's the large tree that we
were talking about
we'll come back to this
at the end but just so you're aware on
the left hand side at the top there is a
bin collection point which is here so
that's not the storage point but it's
the collection point
for in terms of where it is
so this is a street scene showing the
proposed development so you can see the
orange line denotes the existing single
story building so at the moment you've
got quite high eaves with a pitched roof
on top of it so the proposal at that
front element the single story would
drop the eaves down but create a
slightly taller roof with a bit of a
slightly taller pitch to it
and then you've got two other sections
that are set back from that frontage so
you have the section in the middle of
the building as you look at this
elevation here and then on the left hand
side as well to give you that context
in a bit more detail
what that what's being proposed is for
brick work at ground floor aluminium
windows and tile hanging at first floor
giving you the context of that in color
so that's the proposed appearance of the
building
i just ignore the tree on that image
because there's obviously there's a tree
that's set very far back so it's not in
that location
um but you can see that the general
palette of materials that's being
proposed
looking at the side elevation of the
building so this is the elevation that
faces the public footpath
so if you remember that site plan which
showed the staggered build it built form
you've got the single story element at
the front of the building here
then it steps out for this section here
which has got the six
versus emphasis windows and then there's
the main body of the two-story bit of
the building which is in the center so
you can see that when looking at the
previous elevations it showed a pitched
roof pitching away from park lane and
with the dual pitch roof proposal here
with then that rear element that i said
was set in from the neighbor that single
story but with rooms in the roof of that
single story so it's a sort of high
pitch and we'll look at the rear
elevation in a little bit
so in terms of um those main
considerations that i mentioned um the
principal development is looked at in
the report and that's specifically to
pick up some of the points about the
previous use of the existing building
because at one point in the past that
was used as a community building but for
a significant amount of years it hasn't
been used for community facilities and
therefore the principal section is
outlining how
the the demolition of it and effectively
develop of this site developing the site
wouldn't be contrary to our community
facilities policy because it hasn't been
a community facility for more than 10
years
and therefore the use of the moment on
site is is in our view likely to be
lawful
in terms of the main issue that's raised
in the report it's predominantly a in
terms of the design of the building it's
about the relationship with the
conservation area and also the
relationship with the existing open
space on the site so it's considered by
officers the site can be developed as
long as the emphasis on the openness of
that site is still maintained
so that's why what's being proposed here
and this follows pre-app engagement from
the applicant is a staggered design of
the building in terms of the space is
still maintained at the front of the
property
with effectively mimicking the building
that's on there at the moment
within a step design with the main bulk
of the building in the center of the
site at that in that two-story element
now
members will likely have noted
that there's an objection from the
conservation officer on this particular
development who's raised concerns with
regards to the scale and design of the
building um so this is a matter that's
been looked at in quite a bit of detail
um it is considered that there's no
consistent pattern in the area of
development
and in combination with the staggered
design that's proposed that this would
still allow for views into the
conservation area and if just look at
this image here you can see the swathe
of development on the left hand side
there
which would still allow views from park
lane into the conservation area across
this site as well as spacing from the
public footpath uh you know along along
um with in terms of the building and how
it's set back from that um it is
considered that the design by virtue of
this is is sufficiently split up to
avoid the building looking overly deep
or bulky it is acknowledged that it's a
it's a larger you know it's a larger
building
but it's considered by officers that
could be supported on that open space
however it is acknowledged in the
officer report that there is there is an
element of harm to the conservation area
and therefore the report outlines that
when there's any harm to the
conservation area because in this
instance you're you know it's open space
at the moment and you're putting a
building on this space so there's going
to be a physical change whatever you do
on this site that that harm has to be
considered given great weight but
considered against the public benefit of
the development um in accordance with
paragraph 202 of the mppf
so just going through the floor plans of
the development
as with the previous
scheme that we were looking at earlier
all of the required space standards for
these units have been met there's one
two bed a unit which is the unit at the
rear so again just to give members the
context the left hand side of this image
is where park lane is
the public footpath runs along the top
of the image effectively so the unit at
the rear which was that single story but
had rooms in the roof is the two bed
unit which would have access out onto
that rear external space that's provided
so this just shows the first floor plan
important point for members
in terms of the side elevations that are
the sections of the building that are
full to story so this central uh
rectangle the vertical rectangle you can
see which is flats four and five the
side windows in the proposal are to be
obscure glaze and non-opening below 1.7
meters from finished floor level to
avoid overlooking to either the neighbor
at 23 or the neighbor at 17 which is the
one in the conservation area
particularly there are roof lights that
are in the rear element which we saw in
the elevations i think there we go um
so you can see this is from the public
footpath looking towards the building so
as mentioned the windows that are in the
center of this building these are
obscure glazed non-opening below 1.7 the
v-lux windows um are not considered to
result in um significant overlooking to
the neighbor
on a 17-part lane there is an element of
um
it's it's not a private space and we can
look at the photos again if members wish
uh at the front of number 17 uh but we
consider with the obscure glazing of the
windows on the side and with the v-locks
is we you know in terms of them being
clear glaze that that it would be
sufficient to protect the immunity of
neighbours
in terms of
just giving you that more detail about
where the v-luxes are
this is the
roof plan again park lane on the on the
left
public footpath on the top of the image
so again showing that roof form again
how the building has been broken up in
terms of the design
and then these are the other two
elevations of the building
so what you have is at the top the side
elevation that faces towards number 23
um park lane
and i'll show you the context of what's
actually
you know how that sits with the neighbor
but again the top image there has these
two windows here
both of which are to be obscure glazed
and non-opening
below 1.7
meters
and you can see the height on the bottom
image of that single story sort of
two-story element with rooms in the roof
for that two bed unit
and just to give you the
um
the relationship
um i think there we go
so what you have with number 22 next
door is you can see they've got a a sort
of square shape single story rear
extension um and you can see they've got
you know window that faces over the site
as well as the windows that face the
rear
so if i go back
you can see that this square and
hopefully you can all see the mouse
pointer this square at the back here is
that single story addition
so what you would have then is you have
the windows that are directly the
closest windows at first floor
are at this sort of point here on the
plan so following through that line
across there we can see that there's
sufficient distance from the two-story
element here
to avoid an impact on those first floor
windows
plus in terms of if we look at what that
window serves you've got a bathroom
window
on that closest window or certainly a
smaller obscure glazed window and
therefore we don't consider that given
the fact that it's set away and then
staggers when you actually get to the uh
that element there that it doesn't
impact on number 23.
so
so i'm just finding my water
in terms of
the other main issue which is about
parking
the proposal
does not include any on-street parking
to serve the six units now the report
goes into quite a lot of detail about
this because there's been a lot of back
and forth with kcc highways about this
and with the applicant specifically
about the evidence that was produced to
support that lack of parking so
the
application was accompanied by parking
surveys which were carried out two
parking surveys were carried out with
the application
and kcc highways raised concerns that
that wasn't sufficient in terms of an
assessment of the parking availability
in the area and therefore they asked for
an additional survey
to be carried out
the context of the site is
similar but i must admit slightly
different from the last one it is
considered that it's a highly
sustainable location so again you're
less than 100 meters from the square in
birchington and the bus routes in and
out of the district
you're less than the 800 meters that's
normally the rule of thumb for walking
distance to a station so you're less
than 100 800 meters from station so in
terms of both what we would consider and
certainly what inspector would consider
it is a highly sustainable location
in terms of the lack of parking
obviously i think everyone is aware of
park lane in birchington and therefore
one of our main concerns was
about what are the on-street controls in
that area and what is the parking
provision in the wider area so what the
applicant has done is provide those
three parking surveys the last of which
which kcc requested
basically requested an overnight survey
so the other surveys that were provided
were in the day time but obviously the
key here is where do people pile their
cars at night so the survey was carried
out between 12 20 and 1 am
and that covered
the roads around here which i've i've
tried to get a map that shows all of the
roads which covers park lane phillips
road uh barrow close sewell close
linnington road uh cornford road far
road and stone bay avenue now the
methodology for that parking survey
that's been included is from a
methodology that's been produced by uh
lambeth council which kcc have agreed
would be an appropriate methodology and
what that looks at is effectively a 200
meter walking distance that's not a
radius of 200 meters it's actually
walking from one point to another to
look at the areas around there and
whether or not there's sufficient
parking
so
with those surveys coming in kcc
highways considered that they didn't
raise an objection on the lack of
parking due to the location
and therefore we've done exactly the
same test as we were outlined for the
previous report that's been discussed
this evening which is to look at those
two main points that an inspector would
consider which is highway safety and
highway immunity highway safety wise
one of the initial issues that was
raised is whether or not a
parking area could be provided at the
front of the site and obviously you've
got grass verge there concerns raised
about any major new access or parking on
at that point because of queuing traffic
back from park lane effectively and you
already have on street controls along
park lane with bays further up uh i'm
going to go back in the photos sorry
members give me one second
i think i was right at the beginning
isn't it
just hopefully i've got there we go
so you have uh no parking directly in
front of the site yellow lines and then
you've got parking bays which are
denoted further down where you've got
the terrace rows and you can see there
how heavily parked that area is so there
is limited parking available there
however as the report goes into and as
the evidence that's been produced goes
into the roads around there especially
connected via the public footpath to
linnington road has more availability
both overnight and in the day in terms
of the parking spaces that are available
with a potential that's been put forward
for 58 spaces within that 200 meter
walking distance from the site which is
then informed kcc's view
that an objection in their view wouldn't
be able to be sustained given the
location and the lack of parking
there is also the fact that there's a
public footpath next to this site and
you'll see that there's a current from
kcc public rights of way some concern
has been raised about the proposed um
hedgerows that are being proposed or any
sort of boundary treatment um there we
go
along the public footpath um it's not
been considered sufficient to need to
control the planting other than through
a landscaping condition
and obviously what's being proposed
through the landscaping is to provide
additional tree planting at the front of
the site and throughout the site we
don't have the species to be planted
that's why there's a proposal for a
landscaping condition to be put on the
application if approved
um and obviously as mentioned then also
to get the details of that planting
that's to occur along the boundary
so in this application there is the
requirement for a sam's contribution um
as outlined in the report we we don't
have the unilateral undertaking so
therefore the recommendation is to defer
and delegate the application for
approval
subject to the receipt of a legal
agreement which would secure that
contribution within six months of
receipt
thank you chair
thank you very much and um once again i
moved the office's recommendation which
you've
heard is defer and dedicate for approval
vice chair please second
or second lecture members
several i'll go to council art first of
all has he brought this to us thank you
council heart thank you chair um i can't
tell you the number of people have come
and complained to me about this scheme
who i've always just turned around to
just go to planning i mean and put your
complaints in um
it
i don't think it's a bad looking scheme
let's be fair about it i think it fits
the area quite nicely i have no
objection to it in that respect um
the main concern i have with this is
the fact that there is zero parking and
i know it's an issue that we bang our
drum on all the time but the park lane
is absolutely appalling it's one huge
bottleneck in birchington and the fact
that
i i don't believe there's 58 spaces
sorry overnight in in that 200 meter
walking distance because you can't park
you can't even tell it
well i've tried to tow around there and
you can't even get around some of the
callers sometimes it is absolutely
appalling um and i think that this is
just a total over development and i
think that
as a planning committee we should be
looking at this at a more um
holistic
approach to this sort of development in
as much as we've got to look at
what goes on in the local area as ian
pointed out further down park lane you
can park opposite or next to the houses
that are on the left-hand side going out
of the village so they all put in um but
that's not been carried on to the end of
there which you could do but it hasn't
been done disadvantage to that is
obviously as ian said you have the
bottleneck and the and the private path
there but um
it could be done in a way where
if you reduce the amount of properties
on there um
you could put some sort of parking or a
parking turn in there somewhere for
people to get in and i think that um the
belief that people aren't going to have
a car live in this area and just cause
even more chaos is just um
beyond belief really i mean
i just think it's over development i
think it's a nice looking building but
over development and i think the lack of
parking is j is just shocking just
shocking chad thank you
thank you i'm going to bring back ian
i have got you down counselor
um
i i think it was just to
reinforce the issue of um
the concern that was raised about an
access from the front of the site
is effectively the concern about that
relationship with the existing highway
so i absolutely agree with your point
and if members you know feel like there
are too many units and that creates too
much parking
then obviously it's you know it's
something about potentially about the
you know the design of the scheme but
the issue here is that
there isn't in our view a way that you
can develop this site
and provide parking on site that would
be safe i think that's that's the
problem because of creating an access at
the front given its location but
obviously
you know
the the the six units comes with an
amount of parking that's potentially
going to be created in the in the area
[Music]
yeah if i can come back to you i totally
agree with you in totally clear there's
there's no argument about that at all
but if you put a pair of semis on there
then you would have adequate parking it
could be put at the back of you know you
could have parking at the front and as
you say they still have a nice garden
like the rest of the properties in that
road there's no other flats in that road
as
that per se are on the main road there's
a couple down the side roads in the
newer part but i i think it is it's a
shame that people are just trying to get
as much money out of a site as they can
put a pair of semis on there and you can
get the parking and you can still get
the houses thank you
[Music]
thank you counselor heart counselor
bayford
councillor bayford did it
don't know i know it's the heat
well i'm afraid i disagree um
i think
[Music]
there is a
minimal harm to the
conservation area
but i think this is completely this is
outweighed by the provision of six
properties of exactly the type we need
in my view it's very thoughtfully
planned development
when we
decide to buy or rent a property
we can't usually unless we have a lot a
lot of money we can't usually have
everything we want
if you if having a car is important to
you then this isn't the property you
would buy and so in my view
there's no
there's no contest for me i i'd like to
support this
how's the way for cancer right
thank you chair i'm not going to repeat
the things that counselor heart has said
because i totally agree with them um i
think i think this is
the actual design is unsympathetic to
the conservation area to start with
if they change the windows into more
more traditional windows it might make
it look better but
then we come on to the parking
there is no way
that that amount of flats houses would
be could support parking people will
park there and as to the comment
the office's comments about the streets
in and around
park lane
most of the the streets that you you
named all have drives there is no
parking spaces on any of the outbound
streets and there there is also the
thing that you have left out is that
there's a school just up the road
that during during
during school hours it is mayhem in
parklane
it really is it i i won't and i won't be
supporting this application
uh thank you that's right council over
it
uh yeah i mean i think it's an
attractive development and i think we
also have to look at what's there
currently which is not particularly
attractive to my mind and whilst i
understand the merits of the open space
and the views of the conservation area i
think this will be an improvement and
that is a factor to take into
consideration um i'd also suggest that
some however difficult the parking is in
burtington and i admit to known ramsgate
better than i know birchington i mean
parking there isn't going to be more
difficult than it is around hibernia
street
where the previous application was
considered and regardless of that we
have a a view from the um statutory
consulting county council which says
that the parking is satisfactory so
it'll be perverse of this committee to
reach a
different decision and try and
justify refusal on those grounds i'm
just a bit puzzled about the um the the
the land at the front which um i think
the suggestion is that there may have
been cars on there in the past
um
is that access actually a lawful access
to that to that land or is there not a
drop curb there
there is a drop curb that's that's
that's there i don't unfortunately have
the information as to when it was put in
um it's it's not a
it doesn't go into a formalized actually
i'll just go back to the image that's
probably the easiest way
obviously as you can see
it doesn't go on to a hard surfaced area
at all um and therefore um the the use
of that as a drop curb into the site is
is not something that highways would
basically support given what's then gone
on seemingly with the road with the
on-street controls that's occurred and
so you can see it's directly opposite
the access on anvil close as well
um so that's one of the reasons why even
though there's a drop kerb there
you know highways were quite resistant
to putting something on the front
there because it's not really a formal
access in the same way as we would
normally have
thank you
i just like to say counselor over you've
touched on something i was gonna i don't
normally comment on any applications i
think members know that i think um and
totally understand again about parking
um there is a but we have these reports
every month put in front of us and
we rely on not just our offices but
other offices as well to give
correct details and i do understand
what's being said
but i think we've got to be very very
careful on looking at
like this application
regarding there's no parking
and i'm not saying you are going to
refuse it right i'm not saying any of
that that's not down to me that's down
to you i think we've got to be very
careful
um
with our applications are coming into us
we see one early on tonight which was an
excellent application for ramsgate and
for me to say that about ramsgate i
think these
and
you know what i mean i'm only joking but
um i'm not telling you i have no right
to tell you but i think what we've been
learning over the last couple of months
also
um we've we've got to be careful just on
planning grounds if we refuse
thank you members
uh council right again and i'll bring
back yeah just quickly um just be your
clarification
just for your clarification there was
parking on that that site um
it originally was a scout hut and they
parked their vehicles on there and so
did the silver band
uh councillor wing uh it is quite
interesting because if it isn't waste it
is parking and it is quite interesting
that we've had two applications tonight
where i definitely know that the parking
around her bernie street is the damn
site more tricky than here
maybe there's access issues here maybe
it's a busier road and more people need
to turn onto it so that creates a
sort of an equal issue
uh
but you know peop that drop copes there
and if it isn't removed people will go
up onto that if they've got cars so
that's certainly something that would
need to be looked at
uh yeah parking parking waste it's
always a problem isn't it but you know
it looks quite a reasonable development
but we've had two applications where
parking has been an issue one's been
approved
thank you for that council crindon
yeah something along uh similar lines i
do think um that parking could have been
included in this uh proposal um i like
to see the development of the site but
thinking back again to her burnier
street you'd have to walk quarter of a
mile to find parking around there
whereas you're talking about 200 yards
here
um you know it does seem rather ironic
but i also do know that junction quite
well and it isn't a safe junction
as you're coming down down this road
and i do think that the site should have
parking
uh thank you i'll bring back council
heart
thank you chair um
as you know i'm not happy about this
development but if it does go through
can we actually have something that puts
into place that the pavement on the as
you look at that picture where the
houses are there's a pavement and as you
can see people just walk across a dirt
path um to get to the cut through into
the um alleyway which goes on to
uh is it links field or something like
that the estate at the back um can't
remember the name of it um
yeah livington roads yeah that's the one
thank you thank you um but if they if it
does get approved can we make sure that
the um
the developer actually carries on a path
that goes through so there is access and
safe access to that path because
otherwise um people are going to be
pushed across the road to get across to
actually go all walk across their land
and i think we've got to look at it and
as linda quite rightly said you know
that drop curb has been used many a time
especially because it's used as a carpet
storage as well for one of the shops in
the village i think it was um and
he used to park his van down the side
they've all used this that drop curb
silver band as well and i mean they
played there for years um so it has been
used for parking and it's never really
been that much of an issue and i just
think
you know if if we're going to use this
site i mean we're going to agree for it
which some people members here are
inclined to do um
we've got to make it safe for
pedestrians and we've got to put a path
in thank you chair
uh thank you fair point thank you
council
in
um
thank you and and i know i
appreciate that point um so i'm gonna
take the footpath first then i just want
to come back on the drop curb again um
the
this is something that actually has been
looked at because initially the the
proposal included a footpath across the
front of that grass verge as part of the
proposal
and then additional information was
requested by kcc
but the applicant um didn't provide that
information and therefore the actual
proposal to put footpath in was removed
by the applicant from the front now
the issue here is it would clearly be a
positive benefit to have a footpath but
the problem is without providing it
doesn't automatically lead to a highway
safety issue because at the moment
obviously it's a current situation where
people are walking down one side of
parklane would then be potentially
walking out and for development for
people on this site they would be able
to walk out directly onto the public
footpath which is next to the site so
they're not walking out effectively onto
park lane you see what i mean so the i
absolutely agree with your point it
would be definitely beneficial to have a
footpath there but we can't require it
with basically planning backing to get
it because it's not a reason for refusal
to not provide it but if i may on the
drop curve because this has come up
quite a bit
i must admit
i hold my hands up
i have potentially made an error in not
requiring an additional condition on
this application that's before members
because normally what we would do
is remove effectively a redundant
vehicle crossover or remove the drop
curb and so i apologize about that and
i'm doing it i'm doing it live but i'm
going to ask the chairman
whether or not if he's so minded and the
vice chair who second the motion be
surminded um to potentially add a
condition
which would require that the redundant
vehicular crossover
is removed
prior to occupation of these units
again i appreciate it maybe the still
members don't feel it's appropriate to
not have any parking but i think in
terms of a concern about the grass verge
at the front of this site being used for
parking and obviously highways being
saying that they've raised an issue with
actually you know even though i take
your point it's been used in the past
for parking but this would be six flats
potentially unauthorized parking on that
front area which is supposed to be a
landscape grass verge that i think it's
prudent to remove that crossover
before occupation so if the chairman's
so minded to add that condition onto the
existing motion and amend the motion
thank you yes don't kick me um
we'll be over there tomorrow morning
digging it up uh yes i do agree and i
will put that proposal forward and i'm
sure the vice chair will second
i'll second that's yeah
members agree
well yeah okay
sorry you ever come to the motion i'm
sorry okay
keep playing
okay members um
do you wish to
speak anymore
no okay i'm going to put this to the
vote to you which is different delicate
uh could those in favor please
show and that is including
what
i've just suggested that mr livingston
goes over and removes the drop curve
tomorrow morning
so those in favor of this development
those against
abstentions
oh that's carried thank you very much
members thank you
that
concludes tonight's meeting thank you
very much
next meeting will be on august the 20th
i do have an apology already for that
meeting
take care of ourselves in this heat and
thank you very